I can't do this without you
out of what you choose
you'll come out bloody
you
welcome back everyone it's Charlie I
know you've all been waiting for some
new Witcher since they dropped the
teaser trailer back at Comic Con they
just dropped some new footage so we'll
break it down we also have more details
about another big Comic Con panel
happening at the end of the month where
they'll be dropping even more footage so
if you're brand new to my channel I'll
be doing which are videos for all the
episodes be sure to subscribe to get
everything because this is a really big
deal I will do giveaways and all those
videos either for the book series or for
the games whatever you guys want all you
have to do to enter those just be a
subscriber and leave your favorite
Witcher moment on the video starting
with the footage they open with the
butcher of lavich in seen it's the same
group of scenes that they put in all the
trailers just slightly different
versions of what's going on during this
moment the reason why they're hammering
down so hard on these scenes is because
it's such an important part of Geralt
backstory he's called the butcher of
blacken but it sort of ties in with the
theme of the show that sometimes the
monsters are not the worst thing
sometimes people are way worse than the
monsters he's hired to fight there's no
better example of that than the people
that are involved in the butcher of
lavich and both sides
garol sort of gets caught in the middle
of this conflict between two different
groups of people it gets a little
complicated but technically he's
protecting Strega boar this sorcerer
who's kind of a terrible person himself
from this mob here but the mob
themselves are justified in wanting to
kill him it's just that the things that
they do the links that they go to when
they're trying to get him are so extreme
that Geralt is forced to try and stop
them I think this is all made better by
the fact that large mickelson is going
to be playing Strega boar on the series
which I feel like is perfect he plays
some really really great terrible
characters he played a great villain
during Sherlock so quick history lesson
a long time ago
Strega boar hired Geralt to get rid of a
monster inside the kingdom that he was
currently serving once Geralt completed
the contract instead of paying him
Strega Bor reneged on their agreement
and convinced the king that he was a
charlatan and had Geralt run out of town
so already pretty terrible during this
period Strega boar is a firm believer in
the curse of the Black Sun which is a
prophecy foretold by a mage that the end
of human civilization will come at the
hands of 60 girls born during or after
certain eclipses so Strega bore
believing that he's doing good things
goes around full mad
test vivisecting all these young
afflicted girls that he believes will
turn into mutants drowning entire
countries in blood they go around
picking girls it's implied that they
wind up killing a bunch of innocent
young girls in pursuit of this goal so
everyone kind of hates strike abort to
begin with he's already proven through
his actions that he's not that
trustworthy when he ran Geralt out of
town without paying him for his contract
but now he's chopping up all these young
girls who he thinks are going to turn
into mutants stray Gabor is eventually
sent to a different Kingdom called
Creighton because of the Queen's
suspicions that her daughter named Wren
free was born under an eclipse and is
going to turn into a monster he spied on
her conducted all these tests and was
convinced that she would turn into a
mutant so he hired a cutthroat to take
her into the woods and kill her the
cutthroat sexually assaulted her but she
was able to fight him off and escaped
many years later the queen of that
Kingdom wound up dying under mysterious
circumstances stray Gabor suspected that
it was Wren free who had escaped and
come back for revenge many years later
they crossed paths in a different
Kingdom and she tried to kill him he
protected himself by turning her into a
slab of crystal and throwing her down a
mineshaft causing a cave-in eventually
she was rescued by a prince from a
neighboring Kingdom and continued her
quest for revenge against Strega bore
many more years go by
Strega bore has gone to a different town
now called blacken and taken up
residence in a Sorcerer's Tower begins
serving the local populace Geralt winds
up there on unrelated business Strega
boar asks Geralt to kill Wren free
saying that it's the lesser of two evils
because she's completely off the chain
and her quest for revenge ran free in
her gang arrived in bladvic in searching
for Strega boar she appears at his tower
giving him an ultimatum come out
voluntarily or she and her gang will
start killing all of the people in the
marketplace all these innocent people
that are walking around here in this
scene stray Gabor is a coward of course
he refuses to come down so she goes back
to her gang getting ready to kill all
these innocent townfolk when she comes
back to her gang to begin the job she
finds the Geralt has already killin most
of her gang members they begin sparring
and eventually he's forced to kill her
in order to protect all these innocent
people in the street stray Gabor sees
everything from his tower as a super
excited that Geralt has taken care of
this problem for him
down and wants to take her body to
experiment on it because remember the
whole thing that set this off is because
she was born under an eclipse and her
mother the Queen thought that she would
be turning into a mutant eventually so
mad scientist sorcerer Strega Bohr
wanted to experiment on her body but
Garrett refused the request and said
that he would kill Strega Bohr if he
touched her body so that's why Netflix
keeps showing you footage of this scene
because it's such an important idea for
the themes of the show sometimes people
are worse than the monsters that gerelds
hired to fight and even though there are
some really terrible people during this
first season there aren't any real clear
villains because it's just bad people
and worse people going after each other
in that you do have some monsters that
are genuinely terrible that he
definitely has to kill The Witcher book
series is very different from a Song of
Ice and Fire Game of Thrones there's no
night king there's no White Walkers
there's no group of people that you
could point to and say they are the most
evil group everyone else has to band
together to fight them it's really a
bunch of separate groups of people that
are all pretty terrible this is Siri
with the dry as in there forest that's
near sintra this looks like it's
happening after she escapes while the
nilfgaardian Army is invading there's a
couple really big conflicts happening in
sintra but they're compressing the
timeline of the books so Siri goes on
the run when all this craziness is
happening and she winds up here by
accident but because of her elder blood
because she's one of the most powerful
people in the series the dryads also
want her just as bad as the nilfgaardian
stew this is Hunchback yennefer before
she joins the Brotherhood of sorcerers
this is after she's been through her
training you can kind of see the
transformation that she goes through
these scenes of her in the desert seem
like a fight scene when she's using her
new powers all these shots of Geralt in
this keeper broken-down castles seem
like they're from the same sequence of
him being hired to get rid of a Striga
or another monster like he fights in the
opening cinematic of the first game
here's a clip of that it's actually
pretty fantastic scene
that was meant to be princess add a
daughter of king foltest of tameria but
if this is really that Striga then the
time line would be a little bit off but
like they said the showrunner said that
they had to change some of the timeline
from the books and the events to make
the storyline a little more linear and
cohesive for the series this example of
that is making serie way older than she
is in the books for instance in all the
scenes where you see the nilfgaardian
army two strikes intra she's only
supposed to be about ten years old but
here like when you see her with the
dryads she's a teenager in the actress
freya allen who plays serie is about 18
in real life I believe she's playing
Siri just a little bit younger than that
but still way older than books Siri this
seems like a scene of Siri or pavetta
her mother using her powers Siri through
her mother has elder blood making her
one of the most powerful characters in
the book series and in the games one of
her abilities is she can teleport like
you see are looking confused in this
giant mystical tree in the desert she
doesn't know how she got there like
maybe she accidentally used her
teleportation powers this seems like her
mother pavetta using her powers maybe
that's due knee next to her there this
is to saya using her powers she's the
woman and the Brotherhood sorcerers who
takes in Hunchback yennefer and
magically removes all of her deformities
and begins her instruction in the
magical arts it's sort of a nightmare
version of Hogwarts there's some big
sacrifices that yennefer is forced to
make in order to attain her powers this
just seems like her getting into a fight
in the street and then they end
obviously on that same shot of Geralt
all potion DUP getting ready to fight
this giant monster so just a reminder of
the big london comic-con panel with a
showrunner in serie is happening at the
end of the month but that's separate
from the special video game conference
that's happening with the writer of the
book series
they didn't say which of those panels
they're dropping the next trailer at but
netflix will post it online so of course
i'll do a video for it when they drop it
it'll be sometime that weekend and right
now the expected release date is either
going to be later in November or
sometime in December they've already got
a couple of Netflix things that are
premiering around Christmas there was
information that supposedly leaked out
last month saying that The Witcher would
drop around Christmas at the end of the
year but the Netflix came out and said
that that was inaccurate so it might be
some other week during December or late
November of course I'll do videos for
that history bonus videos
or videos just like I would do for Game
of Thrones if you have any special
requests for Witcher videos just let me
know in the comments
everyone click here for my Witcher
comic-con trailer Easter eggs video and
click here for my teaser trailer for the
Game of Thrones prequel series thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]